[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about what happens
baby and today we got gina hi hey
do you have a new tattoo or something i
got a new tattoo hair
and new hair the hair you got a new
tattoo and a new haircut
and i got a new hair i got it and you
got a new job you're a mop this one
i'm a mop because you're mopping your
floors with your whole body
what what she could not perform with her
hair i think
is the no i commented out your picture
you're doing the model pose
and her new occupation is she's a mom
what does your tattoo say
um uh for those i love i will sacrifice
and it's my mom my stepmom's handwriting
and
my little is it written in vietnamese no
okay
and then my step sister drew the heart
at the end that [ __ ] is very straight
thanks and then i got and then i got
don't show the toes for free
yeah don't show them girl oh why not is
that a snake
oh but that doesn't do it justice you
should see it up close it's really
creepy
we match but your snake is way better
than mine
we have it on the same
[Applause]
you got a big stick i got a baby snake
yeah my snake i did it myself
i love it what kind of snake is that his
looks like a
a python mine i don't know uh yeah a red
tail oh
wait a red tail boat it looks like a boa
this one's just a little baby snake
is it a coral snake i don't know it's
got coral snake patterns it's a small
baby
you guys would want to get technical
about the [ __ ] snake does that mean
anything
yeah so do you like snakes i love snakes
my it's my favorite
she used to own a snake a couple no can
i guess what it means
smart huh knowledge oh that's just a
snake
but then you're duplicitous and
two-faced person um
i'm a terrible serpent i wanted to make
sure everyone knew i was a terrible
person
but i got my sister's name on it i got
my favorite flowers on it
and then i got stars and constellations
and uh the leo constellation and the
moon
are you leo dan that's so cool you don't
know she's a leo chick dude
no did you go to her birthday you should
have known from that
some leo [ __ ] dude am i not something
about the horoscopes
wait what does leo have to do with big
parties and stuff leo's love themselves
basically it's the whole thing
yeah we're very like great they need to
be celebrated yeah
and then i have a little star at the
front of the nose it's the first thing
my dad ever taught me how to draw
so when i was a kid oh cool spammed it
everywhere yeah there's a lot of
sentimental value how come you got a lot
of different tattoos at once
huh how come you got all those tattoos
at once i got two
it's all in the same day yeah oh that's
she's just describing what's on the
snake itself
uh on the spot these little things are
on the side all the meanings hold on
there's things on the snake yeah
hold on let me see let's revisit this
joe so my sister
was the tattoo guy wearing a mask it's
like a uh
yeah it's like a woman it's like jewelry
like on the snake there's things yeah
and it's really really small it's really
small smile
so i went to a tattoo shop that i've
been wanting to go to for like 12 years
now
where is it my tattoo in alhambra i know
him
did you get it from him no so just i
wouldn't even i
would never bother him with a small
tattoo oh but we became friends and then
so he had like he did this
when i was under age really yeah
you're underage i'm just i'm just joking
i had to add the joke but he had like
his top person do it for me it was
really cool
man uh lucy oh the girl girl yeah yeah
and then so you're not almost worked
there really he's crazy though isn't he
yeah but he liked me you know why
because you're crazy
uh because you're over age no yeah
i used to go there and he just let me
draw all the time
because i was like yeah i'm serious i
want this tattoo because he wouldn't
tattoo me
and then i was just like uh i wanna just
hang out here on the shop and then i'm
gonna practice tattooing
and after a month he's like all right i
think you're serious
and he uh gave me this tattoo and i was
like all right i want to learn
and then he would talk [ __ ] to all of
his like guys
but then me he would just want to talk
about japan
like all the time and then tattoos and
then
afterwards he says i have to quit
selling weed if i want to work at the
shop and be there
trying to straighten you out [ __ ] that
i'm selling weed man
[ __ ] that you can't tell me to stop
selling weed and then i ran away
you didn't even need to run away he's
just like all right no dad i'm gonna
keep selling weed [ __ ] you in your
tattoo shop i got a shame because i was
like i can't stop selling weed
but it was cool i got to go to the so
what happened was um a few years ago i
helped him promote his show in japan
and then um we became friends on
instagram
and then recently i hit him up and say
hey i want to get a tattoo done do you
have anyone available he's like yeah
just choose whoever you want
how cool yeah you know everyone i have
been
in love with this shop for so long there
was only like two
shops out here that were good though it
was this
i forgot the other one that's quite the
plug as well
[Laughter]
yeah it's really good business man so
they took me in
he's not around anymore is he hot master
mike i think he is ink fiend
yeah yeah okay never mind oh i think
anything's still around oh the plug came
around
yeah yeah yeah but they gave me like the
vip room at night so like i was coming
around anytime at night and i went up
there
and there's just like this big dude
standing there with shirtless like with
tattoos i'm like
ah this is my kind of place and it was
lucy he was like really amazing and then
we should we
had to get until like one in the morning
and it was really pretty
and i'm so happy is it the same shop on
garfield yeah oh man
memories and when i got there they had
like they were doing like a oh
they said let us know when you're
outside we'll walk you in but when i got
there they're like oh give me a second
they had like a they were doing like a
buddhist ritual like a cleansing ritual
oh wow i'm like if i'm about to join a
cult right now i'm okay with it i like
it
[ __ ] maybe they were cleaning it out so
then you can get a good tattoo possibly
i was dope though they're blessing the
culvert away god i would love that
you know the story behind mike um
so when i was there jess had
two guys working there one of them was
mike right yeah yeah
and then there was another dude um a
mexican dude
named indio and um he he was really
really good at the chicano style tattoo
stuff
and then like when i went back they were
gone indio means in
indian and spanish oh really maybe
that's a nickname maybe they called it
but you know how like when people say oh
that's bad
like it's cool right so he was looking
at my tattoo and he goes
man that's bad jess and i was like it is
what's wrong with it and he goes no no
it's cool and i was like oh thank god
that's the worst thing to say when
someone's getting tattooed what does it
mean it's my last name oh okay that one
thing is a whole entire last name
he was disappointed that there's nothing
he shrugged too
i know he looks sick but yeah you know
and there's a stupid reason why
because i i didn't um i didn't know how
to write it
and i didn't know i had to ask my mom
like 10 times to like
write it over and over because i can't
remember and i was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
dude i'm just gonna get a tattoo of it
it's not even my last name and get this
i i [ __ ] myself wait that's not your
last name
it is now wait what okay so here's the
thing
right you didn't you didn't use google
translate like i did
you guys [ __ ] up on how have you here
is the thing right
all right okay so you guys are [ __ ]
soul mates i swear i'm like jealous of
you guys is love
hey at least mine's not my last name
that got [ __ ] up connected by
stupidity
bonded when you hear this story
you're gonna realize what a dumbass i am
but i like my last name right
so okay so here's the thing my last name
um is moma that was my original one my
father's name right
and i was like i don't want to keep it
anymore because he left
so i'm going to legally change my name
but also
maybe i'll set it in stone and like get
a tattoo
of my wait my name would have been joe
moma
it was joe mama yes
i know right i should have kept it you
were born a [ __ ] punchline and you
got rid of it
my dad stick around that would have been
so [ __ ] good greatest comedian name
of all time it was spelled like mama too
m's in the middle oh oh shoot dad knew
exactly what he was doing but they named
you
i want to [ __ ] this kid up the moment
from the moment you're born
i hate your mama from the moment oh my
goodness i can all prove it
and the calligraphy actually looks dope
yeah like that name
when you write it out it looks way
sicker than this but i didn't want to
keep it right
so i asked um my my
grandma like so my mom's made a name i
assumed it was my grandma's
last name which is jitsukawa right and i
was like okay cool i'm just gonna get
that name
and they're like i don't think you
should get that and then i was like nah
[ __ ] you i'm gonna get it
i didn't know that they were telling me
not to get it because it wasn't her last
name
well i mean when they go i don't think
you should it sounds like they're giving
you an opinion well they also didn't
want me to get a tattoo period
it was mixed with them saying don't get
a tattoo at all so it was like
i was confused i was just like well [ __ ]
you i'ma get this tattoo anyway i got it
right
and then a couple of years ago when i
was doing my family history tell your
kid like
don't don't get diesel don't get diesel
you're like [ __ ] i'm gonna get diesel
diesel isn't really my last name and
then and then you but then you didn't
ask them why
like why shouldn't i get diesel well
because also my grandma
used her last name jitsukawa
so i thought it was her last name come
to find out that lazy [ __ ] never
changed it to her maiden name so she
it's not family right
so my grandpa and her had a divorce
jitsukawa is my grandpa's
last name her real last name the
prestigious family which were like
executives to toshiba and all that it's
ito
so that's what i wanted to honor is her
last name
right but he's still my grandpa and my
mom was like yeah he's still my fault it
sounds
tight he was much sicker though it was
much sicker
it's more common think about judge edo
man
that's a famous name james james my
intention
was to honor her because she actually
raised me right
but i ended up where i'm like why the
[ __ ] did you even keep his name
she goes i just didn't want to do
paperwork i was the guy in the family
that left that was an
alcoholic gambleholic who destroyed the
family fortune
and my grandma divorced will you like to
gamble i do
that's good i mean you won yeah i know
so i guess it all kind of
played out right so it's fun to gamble
in life i mean in life yeah but not with
your finances and that's why
speaking of our brand deal of store
you're welcome for that
yeah and that's why i uh really like
upstart for sponsoring this podcast
during these tough times everyone is
looking for a way to feel more
financially secure and if you're still
throwing money
every month at high interest credit card
debt it's time you checked out upstart
the revolutionary online
lending platform that knows you're more
than just a credit score now is the time
to find out
how low your upstart rate can be to help
pay off high interest credit card debt
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your education and job
history in the form of a smarter rate
but you don't need a degree or diploma
to apply upstart lets you skip going to
the bank because it's completely online
they offer loans from a thousand to
fifty
thousand dollars so you can consolidate
your debt into one easy
fixed rate payment that's big money
upstart makes it fast and simple to
check your rate
since it's just a soft pull it won't
affect your credit score
the hard pull happens if you accept your
rate and proceed with your application
the best part of the loan is approved
and accepted most people get their funds
the very next business day a lot of
money really fast yeah
so over 400 000 people have used upstart
to pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt
and get back to using your money your
way with upstart
see why the [ __ ] upstart has 4.9 out of
5 rating on trustpilot
and hurry up to upstart.com record
r-e-c-o-r-d to find out how low your
upstart rate can be so if your shit's
all [ __ ] up and you want to clean it
up
go check it out upstart.com
record r-e-c-o-r-d record so i found
this out um two years ago when my
grandma was still alive she had
alzheimer's so she probably forgot the
fact that i had a tattoo anyway
but we had this conversation and and i
was i was able to ask her like why
didn't you ever change it
and um she was actually able to answer
it so her mind was kind of still sharp
yeah she was just like yeah i didn't you
know back then it's just you don't get
divorces first of all and then second
you know it's just difficult to go to
the courts and like get it changed
legally and i was like
you're in america for like over a decade
how come you didn't do it here she goes
i want to pay the lawyer fees
it's a lot of [ __ ] time and money man
[ __ ] that i wouldn't do that either
right
do you have any advice for your kids
about tattoos since you have learned so
many things about them
hell nah do whatever the [ __ ] you want
[ __ ] it
any advice especially knowing this
because i think i feel like
no regrets no no not even one it makes
for a good story it does make for a good
story
right you'll also realize
how [ __ ] dumb you are because
something that's so
like meaningful and all that [ __ ] like
and permanent
right so like i was living a lie right i
[ __ ] put this [ __ ] on
and then i'm gonna be like yeah i'm
representing my grandma
and then she's like actually that was my
divorced husband
but it's cool you know what i mean you
could tell you're gonna lie
it was worthwhile to get that tattoo
actually that name brings me pain
i'm like i'm honoring my grandma she's
like that's actually not my last name
and i'm like why didn't you tell me this
she goes i still love them
oh that's cute yeah so and my mom was
like
i don't mind it like it's my last name
and i and then my dad was good to me
but that's good my intentions were just
[ __ ] because
that's not what i wanted to do you know
what i mean and yours is like we're all
[ __ ] or something
he no his tattoo is i'm afraid of
everybody
so that's what makes me laugh every time
that's the lesson
that's the lesson that i would teach
people or at least my kids don't
don't use google translate um yeah
no do it so we have stories like this
google translate at least back in those
days they didn't have uh it was not
grammatically correct
it's still pretty [ __ ] up now and it
was a random white guy in north carolina
that was like i'm just gonna trust you
on this oh no
at least his life is very clean like the
like he was a good
tattooer yeah it looks good but i also
got it with my best friend at the time
we're not best friends anymore
you got two dudes i got matching tattoos
that are wrong
god i'm so glad i never got the tattoos
i wanted when i was young
that's the one thing like when you're
when you're young you get the stupidest
and dumbest [ __ ] i probably get stupid
[ __ ] right now
and that's probably why i just stopped
getting tattoos all together remember we
were gonna get koalas in
australia i don't think i would have
regretted it i wanted that one i really
wanted that one i don't know
what stopped you guys i remember that
conversation we literally spent like
with you guys i was just like okay we're
gonna visit five miles
and you know why we didn't get it well
you know what there wasn't any good the
shops were horrible
and it was all the apprentice there but
it's for the memory now
yeah it's for the memory now and i'm
like i i would have happily had a [ __ ]
you should have got [ __ ] tattoos but i
think we were like
too uh snobby we were kind of tattoo
snobs you know
and i don't think gio had her tattoo not
yet so for her first one she wanted
something super try
yeah yeah and then i was kind of like at
this phase where i was learning the
tattoo too so i was like
or i just learned and i'm like yeah you
shouldn't be we [ __ ] up
we should have gone you just just
[ __ ] went for it you should have just
got it in english and then you kind of
want to know what was going on
the translation on i feel like i'm
scared of everyone you even get in
chinese english and not australian what
is it
it's japanese so he couldn't read it
we're trying to be fair
he could read chinese so we're so uh my
best friend was korean
i'm chinese so far i'm trying to we're
trying to get like so this is like a 19
18 year old thought process right
where like your two best friends and
you're like all right we got to get
something matching to represent like a
warrior spirit that we share we both
love
all right but we can't get in chinese
because that's unfair it's like biasing
me
we can't get in korean because then
that's biasing towards
the back that's like a middle ground oh
japanese is kind of in the middle
cool and now it's a language that both
of us don't know i [ __ ] hate you guys
upsetting [ __ ] the whole process is a
struggle
and then can you imagine like two asian
guys that show up to a tattoo shop like
a random like tattoo shop in north
carolina they're like
okay you guys want magic tattoos well
they didn't
even question you can write chinese
right yeah and you
even know that the order of which the
lines
are written uh changes like the stroke
pattern
and it can it it doesn't change the word
but it can make it incorrect
yeah so you got it from a white guy that
doesn't know the
order of which it's done no i mean i
printed it out
on a really nice inkjet printer so i
didn't think it could be wrong
oh my god but he was just copying it and
the printer messed up
that's right got it and you know how he
found out it's when my mom read that and
she was like
who's he afraid of and i'm like what do
you mean she goes
that thing says i don't think that's
right
and i was telling him she goes you told
him like he's gonna have to live with
that
oh you laughed though right what do you
mean you laughed
when you found out oh then yeah i mean
by that time like me and joe have
already embarrassed ourselves beyond
belief like we were uncle sam uncle jim
like
it made it really good it didn't even
[ __ ] matter but if it was like in my
days i'm trying to be a cool guy
i probably cried my privately cried my
brains out that's the best thing about
it though
is that that the people who would cry
about it now
i feel so bad for those people yeah
because it's such a great thing that you
can laugh at
yeah you'll get a tattoo and it says
[ __ ] but they're like man it means
warrior
they're like wait no i'm not a [ __ ]
come on man i'm not a [ __ ]
like those guys are my favorites like
googling like laser tattoo removal
so they cannot be a [ __ ] now yeah
because now they're tagged as a [ __ ]
yeah
i feel like tattoos now it's pretty
common to the point where it's a part of
fashion and clothing and culture
and um it doesn't have the same stigma
that we had growing up because like
my first um real real girlfriend were
like she lived with me and everything
i was like 19 she was like um in her
early 20s
and she was sleeved up and that was like
pretty big for the that's gangster
that's gangster stuff yeah and i would
tell one lesson i learned is i would
tell
if i had a daughter do not get a trans
uh
uh trans trap snap of your ex's name
in graffiti font on your [ __ ] lower
back blind but it just says jitsukawa
and
no it says like her ex boyfriend's
boyfriend's first i didn't even know
so i didn't like to get i didn't like
the doggy stuff i wouldn't either
because i looked down and i'm like
that's a nice booty but that's also
somebody's name
just don't get any significant other's
names period don't get names
at all i got my sister's name that's
fine like she can't unsister me
get your own name no that's stupid
because it's like why did you forget
your own name
yeah like me
[Laughter]
i'm beginning to think tattoos aren't a
very good idea
[Music]
you